am I gonna shove more hotdogs down this
gullet you can bet my sweet fine we are
in Chicago Illinois that's right known
for a couple of things it's for teams
and hang out our good friend Annie
behind the camera it was like why don't
we try the top three places on Yelp and
see if they're actually as good as they
say they are cuz Yelp is a very powerful
tool that we use to find restaurants
here's the thing though
if sometimes is an unfair way that does
very strongly affect small businesses
and it's very subjective - yeah take
everything Yelp with a grain of salt
Chicago style hot dog is poppy or sesame
fun yellow mustard onions relish
tomatoes hot peppers a long pickle and
that's usually it it's very simple and
there's really there's never kept on
there what no gay jokes no what am i
running behind you got
[Music]
Fatso's fun thing about Fatso's is that
their dogs are charred on the grill
they're a little bit crispier than I
think your average hot dog a little
burnt on the end yeah they're a little
bird little smoky you know look at that
yeah it's pretty big one hot diggity dog
sesame seed bun I think the char
actually gives it a little bit of a more
of extra flavor which I appreciate this
is a dangerous place okay if I lived
like right on this corner probably be
eating here like at least a week they
gave us a lot of fries this thing is
overflowing with onions we've having fat
cells right you know my eyes can't be
that good four and a half stars though
on Yelp it does not you know it's not
too happy
yeah thank you good I don't what I
thought Danny why do I do this this is
your ball it's a good point of me
[Music]
all right this is spot number two we're
at UB dogs and we got their Chicago hot
dog
this is there Joey dog they're doing it
is a very beautiful doll yeah Joey dog
is pretty intense looking all right so
good your thanks are you know I'm gonna
love this this is the hot dog I ate all
the time growing up it's why I never put
ketchup on my hot dogs here it's really
asking me kills with a pepper cake
there's a little bit of spice to these
hot dogs all of the condiments are
expertly seasoned two hot dogs and a
drink and price of under $10 is a very
good deal yeah I'll give him proper that
little soggy bun sometimes like a little
bit crispier but although pretty decent
dog you today if I weren't in a hot dog
and I was looking up when I found this
place when I came here I would be just
fine I won't touch up on this Danny
[Music]
okay the number one rated place on Yelp
for hot dogs in Chicago it's pretty
small I do love the logo it's the mascot
it's pretty good
that is a immense pickle it's not as
photogenic as you would expect it to be
it is a very unique experience eating
this hotdog actually the meat on this
hotdog is more flavorful it's memorable
if that bite is just like all this
pickle coming in I clearly be like it
you do I get yeah I like it a lot it is
the least attractive hotdog we've seen
it's like coming up nobody's it's
apparently but I think this is my
favorite hot whoa I can't believe it it
was a nostalgia factor that really
brought it home today we'll probably go
with you be hmm just like bursting
ingredients and flavor and it was yeah
we good thing with something pill over
here I'm not sure you can have like a
favorite one when at the end of it you
just you do want to die
you're gross